new details on the shocking attempted
murder of a sitting supreme court
justice pro-abortion protesters showing
up last night right in front of brett
kavanaugh's home just hours after a man
was arrested with plans to assassinate
him that suspect armed with a gun knife
zip ties and duct tape plus other things
and a plan to kill the justice and then
himself
many wondering why president biden has
not verbally mentioned the threat on
kavanaugh's life even though there's
been ample opportunity to do so the
president sounding off on the end of roe
versus wade last night on late night
television though
there's a whole range of things that are
at stake here when we talk about
eliminating roe v wade it's clear that
if in fact the decision come down the
way it does and these states impose the
limitations they're talking about it's
going to cause a mini revolution they're
going to vote a lot of these folks out
of office
that comes as house democrats stall on a
bipartisan bill meant to increase
security for the justices and their
families i spoke with federal judge
esther solis this morning she lost her
son to a crazed gunman who showed up at
their home on the importance of such
bills
we need to do something to protect all
federal judges across this nation
and the daniel anderle bill
is a concrete step in the right
direction but this is this is i mean we
just saw judge romer assassinated in
wisconsin last friday
when is it going to stop this country is
in trouble democracy is in trouble and
we need to have our leaders stand up and
say we're going to lead our justice
system is in trouble
and
judges stand on the front line
protecting
democracy so there's a lot to cover here
jesse let me start with you on this
pretty amazing that uh you can imagine
if it was somebody else they probably
would have said something but brett
kavanaugh is almost like sub-human to
them yeah i mean republicans
we have to condemn when someone tweets
something right
and someone
has an assassination attempt and they
don't have to say anything i this has
given me such clarity
over the stakes of what we're dealing
with with these leftists and how evil
some of these people are the president
of the united states should not be using
the word revolution
on the heels of an assassination plot
against a supreme court justice
they say words matter that's a word that
matters you right now have joe biden
kamala harris she has not said anything
on camera schumer has not even put out a
statement from what i gather and garland
still hasn't arrested any of these
protesters who are breaking federal law
outside his house the media is just
stone cold evil here the new york times
doesn't put it on the front page usa
today doesn't put it on the front page
and the cable news
pundits are both sizing it and burying
it and they're saying oh you know what
it happens this and that side and this
side and you know this is going to get
crazy
i don't like what's happening because if
you look at it from their perspective
you could argue that this is a
conspiracy and they like the heat on
kavanaugh because you have the leak
and then you have the hands-off approach
from the justice department you have the
insightful words from schumer and then
zip zilch from the highest leaders in
the united states kamala and joe so what
does that do that gives license to the
wood bees and wannabes and mini
revolutionaries
so you have to think how far do they
want to take it how far are they going
to push this thing it seems like they
want to push it right to the edge and
this country cannot have that and they
need to dial it back and be a little
more responsible before something really
really ugly gets happening and i think
we're this close to something really
ugly happening last night lindsey graham
said on the show he thinks we're this
close to an assassination geraldo well i
hope that lindsey graham is wrong so do
i and uh it's absolutely disgusting what
they're doing with brett kavanaugh or a
man who's been really cruelly treated
since he went into the uh
the supreme court arena
but on the other hand the house and
senate have moved rapidly to pass
legislation to protect or to promote
legislation and soon to pass legislation
to protect supreme court judges with the
same kinds of protection that senators
and others get uh and i think that you
know we are shocked into action by
something as outrageous as this but i i
i will say one thing the one thing that
disturbs me and you're talking about
priorities and jesse i understand your
frustration with with liberal media
my frustration is also with conservative
media and conservatives in government
look how fast they move to protect
supreme court judges
where is the action to protect the
school children of vuvalde and other
places where is the congressional action
aren't they the pastor
they are paid they are doing bogus
nothing they're hashing it out
cashing out nothing and it's going
nowhere there will be no juvenile
assault weapons ban there will be
nothing meaningful that happens in the
congress of the united states they are
absolutely
not only dysfunctional they they just
don't care and when you say that one
side emphasizes one thing the other side
emphasizes the other when are these
people going to do the right thing not
for their party but for their couple
they're trying to respect the
constitution also
because the house has slow walked these
supreme court security bills and that
was just okay look the the bill to
protect supreme court justices and
provide security was passed bipartisan
unanimous in the senate okay
nancy pelosi is holding it back this is
in may that it passed all right she
won't let it out in all of may all of
june she says maybe she'll get to it
next week we're talking right now about
the attempted assassination of a supreme
court justice we're talking about a
president of the united states who's
talking mini revolution chuck schumer is
talking about you release the the
whirlwind and you're going to have to
suffer for it and maxine waters who says
get confrontational get in their faces
i'm telling you right now merrick
garland should be thrown out of office
for not arresting every one of those
people in front of kavanaugh's house
last night he has an obligation and i'm
sick of their empty words where merrick
garland yesterday says you know it's a
threat to our democracy to them the only
thing that's a threat to democracy is
parents fighting for their children in
schools and if you were involved in
january 6 where people are still being
held in in isolation and solitary
confinement not this past january
january before but here's what i'm
concerned about let you know with dana
i'm going to take an extra 30 seconds i
am sick and tired of the republicans
laying down every time the democrats are
in charge the republicans act like you
know they've got their white gloves on
when when scalise was shot by a bernie
sanders supporter and the democrats said
oh let's not be political the
republicans said okay let's be friends
kumbaya and then this kind of thing
happens and they then want to throw
everybody in jail and everyone who did
something in january 6 they should go to
jail if they violated the law but this
is an attempted assassination on a
supreme court justice and they don't
give a damn that the president of the
united states who go on national
television and not one media has heard
him apologize is disgusting and they as
far as i'm concerned when the
republicans get in office if they don't
do something have a moral courage and a
fortitude to get these people back in
line then you know what they don't
deserve our votes one of the things
that's frustrating is that the laws
aren't followed right and people aren't
so you are not allowed to protest
outside a federal judge's home they had
ample opportunity to do so last night
they had advanced warning and they
decided not to do it right and if this
were sotomayor's house
would those protesters still be left
there and if one of them were shot would
the cop be a hero
right
there's a reason why this isn't being
covered there's two reasons one is that
the press can't cover this because their
fingers or all fingerprints are all over
the relentless demonization of kavanaugh
among other people i mean it's enough of
a demonization based on this roe v wade
leak and other things that it took uh i
would say an impressionable introvert
and radicalize him into a spectacle
seeking suicide right i mean this is
what this he's never done anything
before but he was clearly influenced
that's one reason they know that they're
partially responsible so they really
can't cover it that's why the new new
york times was on page like 8 20 or
something like that they're not by the
way it's not anywhere it's not anywhere
number two they cannot counter program
against january sixth there's nothing
that exposes your exaggerated threat
than a real unambiguous direct threat
with a guy with a glock
why is a fully armed leftist showing up
to kill a judge not being covered
because he's a leftist and it's on the
day of this hearing all we ask or all i
ask is that we that legitimate
assassination attempts of supreme court
judges get the same attention that maybe
a guy an unarmed guy dressed up as a
viking stealing a pelosi podium would
get that's all that's all but that can't
happen because that's counter
programming against a trumped-up turd of
a show trial i mean these are people
that threw a fence around the capitol
because somebody sneezes and here they
don't do crap hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else